the minute when you were talking about
this this bounce uh that happens in say
Loop Quantum cosmology yes sir um
there is a sense in which like there is
um you know I once heard um
um
given analogy that somehow when we think
about since it is a quantum theory and
geometry is quantized then the idea was
that the perhaps a Quantum reason behind
the bounce is that as space-time you
know if you think about the sort of the
structure space-time being cellular or
discrete
um it is but you get to some you get to
some region and there is some repulsive
question forces so is that the thing
you're you're kind of pointing to yes
that's a I'm I'm seeing exactly that the
Super Force resides at the ashtaker
bounds it is the Super Force that
actually possibly uh at Super density
condition and what super density really
density at playing scale so it's your
you know uh speed of light to the fifth
power the whole thing divided by the
denominators like uh a big G Square H
bar your H bar is your reduced plan
cancer and that's how h-bar comes in
because Professor ashtaker when he heard
of the my formula for the Super Force it
was like but the the it's not Quantum in
nature can be fundamental but it talks
to a super density
and and the beauty of it is because it
doesn't have the H bar that it couples
with the Einstein equations as as you
and I have been conversing you and I can
discuss this more because I see you know
I see your point very well as well so so
but what I'm saying is what if the Super
Force is what makes the ashtaka balance
happen when you say that the Super Force
resides at the Ashton car bounce do you
mean to say that the Super Force comes
into play at the level when the Ashton
car bounce becomes relevant or the Super
Force is the ash to car bounce no no no
no no the ashtaker bounce is this
Quantum bounce that uh that Professor
Alexander was speaking of that basically
can be used instead of uh inflation
Theory and so forth to but anyway look
what I'm trying to say uh let me let let
me Focus uh on the thoughts because this
is important let me give the analogy of
a supernova explosion the way the way it
does it the way uh for example anything
about a type 1A uh Supernova this would
apply to the mechanism is basically that
of a core collapse that leads to
something called core bounds and it
happens at very high densities on the
order of like 2.4 times 10 to the 14
grams per centimeter Cube
at those extremely high densities this
core bounds occurs because of the what
the strong nuclear force comes into
being and this thing it's what leads to
the um uh extremely violent expulsion of
the outer core of the star so I'm saying
I'm taking something that's extremely
small and analogizing it with something
that happens in a supernova mechanism
but it's almost the same idea the core
bounce really happens in this case
because of the extremely high density
which brings in the strong nuclear force
and I'm saying at the quantum bounds
it's not the strong nuclear force it's
the Super Force that acts
and what's really interesting and I hope
to prove this to Professor Alexander one
day I really hope you sir I really hope
you take the time to to read the paper
that I have in mind I wish I had the
pedigree of a physicist so maybe you're
able to I mean and I'll try in that
paper to to make much stronger
mathematical arguments as to what I'm
saying but from a physical mechanism
point of view just think of the analogy
of a core bounce that happens upon the
core collapse of a supernova explosion
that's exactly what I'm talking about
but on a Quantum level you just watched
a clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy